in this video we're going to be talking
about pathogens and how an environment
might help or hurt the spread of a
pathogen
so first of all let's make sure we know
what a pathogen is
patho comes from greek pathos which is
referring to disease
gen you might recognize that part of
word from words like generate or
genetics it means to produce so a
pathogen is something that produces
disease
now a good example of a pathogen that
we're still facing on our planet is
malaria
and malaria is a very very unpleasant
disease it involves the attack on red
blood cells it causes fever chills
sweats severe abdominal pain vomiting
headaches it can make you more
susceptible to other diseases and if
it's not treated it can kill someone
now the pathogen
that creates or that produces malaria
that causes the disease malaria is known
as plasmodium falciparum
and this right over here is a picture of
it attacking red blood cells we see
healthy red blood cells right over here
and then the ones that are in this deep
color this is being attacked by the
malaria pathogen and as it does that it
destroys those red blood cells and it
leads to all the symptoms that i talked
about
so let's think a little bit about the
environment in which malaria is likely
to be spread
well there's a few things that we know
we know that the malaria pathogen can
only operate can only go through its
full life cycle in relatively warm
conditions it needs to be greater than
20 degrees celsius which is the same
thing as
68 degrees fahrenheit
we also know that it is spread through
mosquitoes in particular this mosquito
right over here the anopheles mosquito
and mosquitoes are unpleasant even when
they aren't zoomed in like this but this
is actually quite frightening
and we all know what mosquitoes like to
do at least to human beings they drink
our blood and so you need an environment
where both mosquitoes can thrive and
there's a lot of human hosts whose blood
they can drink and where they can spread
the malaria pathogen from one host to
another
so i ideally you'd like a high
population density
and for the mosquito spread you
definitely want a hot
and humid
environment so you might guess
that if you're looking for things that
don't dip below this because if you dip
below this the malaria pathogen is not
going to be able to go through its life
cycle you're likely looking at regions
in the equator and this map right over
here confirms our intuition what you see
in these orange regions are where you
see the highest prevalence of malaria
the yellow regions are where you might
see malaria but not as high of a
prevalence and then the blue areas are
where you don't see malaria
and as we guessed if you look generally
at where the equator is
that is where you're likely to see
malaria because it is warmer there you
don't see temperatures dip and then you
also see hot humid environments in
sub-saharan africa the sahara desert is
roughly right over there and that is
very dry not good for mosquitoes but if
you look at sub-sahara right below this
you have a high prevalence of malaria
now one not so comforting realization is
as the earth warms you're going to have
more regions that are not just tropical
regions not just equatorial regions that
are going to be suitable for the spread
of malaria
so
easily you could have what are
traditionally subtropical environments
or even temperate environments
that if it gets warm and hot and humid
enough you might see the spread of
malaria over time
and malaria and the malaria pathogen
aren't the only things that might spread
you have things like the zika virus
which is a virus not a protist in the
case of malaria but a virus that's also
spread by mosquitoes so it also thrives
wherever mosquitoes might be able to
thrive and the warming more humid
environment isn't just going to support
the spread of mosquitoes it could
support the spread of other pathogens
like bacteria which could cause diseases
like cholera which is caused by infected
water
so i'll leave you there i like to be a
little bit more upbeat about things but
it's just good to realize that this is
out there and as our environment changes
it's not just the environment effect
that it affects but it could also affect
the spread of disease